hey guys Dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about neuroma pain now what is a neuroma
it's basically fibrous tissue that's scar tissue
that wraps around a nerve at the bottom of your
foot making it very difficult to walk and it's
usually between to what's called metatarsals which
are the bones in your foot which I will show you
in just a moment okay so it's a scar tissue that
wraps around the nerve that makes it very painful
to move your foot or walk on it now what causes
neuroma neuromas or Morton neuromas they don't
know but I believe it comes from an old injury
which is going to relate to how I'm going to show
you how to get rid of the pain but I believe this
technique I'm going to show you is the only way
you're going to knock out pain without drugs and
surgery you want to see I'll show you okay guys
this is how you do it number one let's pretend she
has pain right here and these are the metatarsals
these extensions of these toes right through here
okay so usually going to have a neuroma like
right about here or here maybe right here now
what you're going to do you're going to press on
the opposite foot that mirrors the image of where
that neuroma is so if it's between this little
pinky one to mark now between this little toe
and this tail right here you'll press between
this little toe in this toe on the mirror image
opposite side now when I press on the opposite
side what you're going to notice it's going to
hurt like hell okay so go light and you can do
this on yourself if you like pain now just going
you could do this on yourself or get someone else
to do it but the key is pressing on the opposite
foot no one does this what they're going to do
is are going to work on where the injury was do
therapy it's going to make it worse especially if
you got surgery for it it's like a reit Ramah it's
like hitting your thumb over and over again so
we're going to press on the up to side and you're
going to just massage it and you're going to find
oh my gosh that's still painful in fact this side
will be more painful than this side when you press
on it but not normally now go light the first time
okay so you're actually sending a signal up to
the brain to turn these pain signals off that's
what you're doing so you're working on the nerve
signals because it's not a feedback loop this foot
is connected to this foot through the spinal
column okay now here's a little trick what
you want to do the way that you know you found
the exact spot is to find the point of the most
pain okay so you might want to go up a little bit
down to the left to the right and you're going to
hit like the epicenter of the pain and then what
you're going to do is you're going to just stay on
that point and work that and then what you can do
you can you know ask yourself how is this feeling
now and I like to rate it can being really bad
zero being no pain and I keep you know kind of
rating the pain it's going to come down down down
down down till it's at zero it's gone but what
happens is this pain original pain might shift it
might move over to the left right up or down so
what you do is you just move your finger to the
opposite or mirroring mirroring that pain and
keep working that out until all the pain is gone
okay now what's going to happen you're going to
decide it's going to feel really really good okay
you're going to walk on it and then the next day
you're going to do it again and this might even
be a little sore so you want to go light at first
until finally over like a week or two when it's
like really minimal okay this doesn't necessarily
correct the neuroma it gets rid of the pain from
the neuroma it's a great technique in fact it's the
only technique that I know that'll knock the pain
out better than any drug or surgery without the
side effects okay so go ahead and attempt this
at your own risk and put your comments below